This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It was the night of March 30th, 2005, and the Powerball Jackpot was $25 million. On TV, the White Ping Pong Balls rolled out one by one as the host announced the winning numbers. 22, 28, 32, 33, 39, and your powerball is 42. That's producer Avery Trouffleman. And there was a winner in Tennessee, but the way that Powerball drawings work, there are usually some second place winners, who guess all of the numbers except for the very last one.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。那是2005年3月30日的晚上，强力球彩票的奖金高达2500万美元。电视上，白色的乒乓球一个接一个地滚出来，主持人宣布了中奖号码。22、28、32、33、39，你的强力球号码是42。那是制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。田纳西州出现了一位中奖者，但按照强力球开奖的工作原理，通常还会有一些二等奖获得者，他们猜中了除最后一个号码之外的所有数字。
On average, there are three or four of these players. But on March 30th, 2005, there were 110 second place winners. Was there a computer glitch that played all the same number, like, has someone compromise a system? This is journalist Jennifer Aitley. Lottery officials are panicking, because like something is up. So the next day, as the winners around the United States came to collect, the Powerball officials asked them. So where did you get your number from? And each of them had the same answer.
平均而言，会有三到四个这样的玩家。但在2005年3月30日，有110名二等奖获得者。是不是有电脑故障导致大家押了相同的数字，或者说有人破坏了系统？这是记者詹妮弗·李。彩票官员们惊慌失措，因为情况有些不对劲。因此，在第二天，当全美国的赢家们前来领奖时，强力球官员询问了他们。那么你们的号码是从哪里来的呢？每个人的回答都一样。
They had gotten their numbers from a fortune cookie. They were different cookies in different states, but they all had the same fortune and the same lucky numbers. same lucky numbers. Very lucky numbers. And so it just sort of made you realize how much fortune cookies and Chinese food have become an American ritual. Chinese food, along with pizza and the Frankfurter, has been adopted and modified to become American cuisine, rooted in some good old fashioned American xenophobia. In the early waves of Chinese immigration in the 1850s, the new Chinese population worked mostly
他们的号码来自幸运饼干。它们是不同州的不同饼干，但它们都有相同的幸运签语和相同的幸运数字。非常幸运的数字。所以这让人意识到，幸运饼干和中餐已经多么深地融入了美国的某种仪式。中餐，连同披萨和法兰克福香肠一起，被吸收并改良成了美国菜肴，这根植于某些陈旧的美国仇外心理。在1850年代的早期华人移民潮中，新来的华人人口主要从事
as miners and farmers and laborers. And Americans, as ever, were concerned about these new immigrants taking away jobs. And it was actually only after a huge anti-Chinese backlash that the Chinese actually moved into two fields. One was laundry, the other one was restaurants, so these were cleaning and cooking, which are women's work, and thus they were safe and no longer threatened the American male. And as their livelihoods depended on it, Chinese restaurant owners made up dishes to cater to American tastes. Americans basically like things that are sweet in their fried and are chicken. And that's how dishes like chapsuui were invented. Chapsuui, the name actually means assorted pieces, like odds and ends.
矿工、农民和体力劳动者。和往常一样，美国人担心这些新移民会抢走工作。事实上，正是在一次大规模的反华热潮之后，中国人才真正进入了两个领域。一个是洗衣店，另一个是餐馆，这些都是清洁和烹饪，属于妇女的工作，因此它们是安全的，不再对美国男性构成威胁。由于生计全靠它们，中餐馆老板为了迎合美国人的口味捏造了一些菜肴。美国人基本上喜欢甜的、炸的和鸡肉的东西。这就是杂碎这样的菜肴被发明出来的过程。杂碎，这个名字实际上意思是各种各样的碎块，就像零碎杂物一样。
Oh, chapsuui is the biggest culinary joke that one culture has ever played on another. Chapsuui is not a real Chinese dish, at all. It's as American as apple pie, and speaking of apple pie. Americans want dessert because we are American and we like things which are sweet and fatty, so you need to dessert. And as Chinese desserts go, there aren't that many options that the American palette would go for. The Chinese desserts are like, there is the mooncake, which tastes and looks like a hockey
哦，杂碎是不同文化之间开过最大的饮食玩笑。杂碎根本不是一盘真正的中国菜。它就像苹果派一样美国化，说到苹果派。美国人想要甜点，因为我们是美国人，我们喜欢甜的和油腻的东西，所以你需要甜点。至于中式甜点，美国人的味蕾能接受的选择并不多。中式甜点就像是，有一种月饼，它的味道和外表都像一个曲棍球
puck, but there's not a lot of stuff. In so around the 1920s, the fortune cookie somehow enters the American Chinese restaurant culture, where they came from originally is a bit of a mystery, but we'll get to that. First, let's make this perfectly clear. The cookies are not from China. I don't know why the Chinese they don't eat the fashin cookie. Steven Yang is founder of Yang's fortunes incorporated in San Francisco. Chinese people in China don't eat fortune cookies,
球，但没有太多其他东西。所以在1920年代左右，幸运饼干不知怎么地进入了美式中餐馆文化，它们最初来自哪里有点神秘，但我们会讲到这一点。首先，让我们明确一点。这些饼干不是来自中国。我不知道为什么中国人他们不吃幸运饼干。史蒂芬·杨是旧金山杨氏财富公司（Yang's Fortunes Incorporated）的创始人。中国的中国人不吃幸运饼干，
but Americans consume billions of them, which means great business for Steven, because he prints a lot of the paper fortunes that go inside fortune cookies. If you go anywhere, I would have knew your boss done chutes done anywhere, or you can see my fortune. Including all the fortunes for Panda Express. That's definitely Steven's biggest client. Steven's tiny warehouse in San Francisco's Dog Patch District
但美国人消耗了数十亿个，这意味着史蒂芬的生意兴隆，因为他印刷了大量夹在幸运饼干里的纸条。如果你去任何地方，无论是在旧金山唐人街还是其他任何地方，你都可以看到我的幸运签语。包括熊猫快餐的所有签语。那绝对是史蒂芬最大的客户。史蒂芬位于旧金山狗补丁区（Dog Patch District）的小仓库
is filled with boxes. All stuffed full of tiny strips of fortune paper. Each box contains 300,000 paper fortunes. And Steven prints all these boxes and boxes with only five other employees. And Lisa, Steven's daughter, writes all the fortunes. When I visited, she was away on maternity leave, but she has written most of the company's 5,000 unique fortunes. When I visited, she was away on maternity leave, but she has written most of the company's 5,000 unique fortunes. This is amazing because when you think about it, fortunes are deceptively difficult to write. The messages have to be really, really generic because they could be for anyone. You can't write messages like you will meet a tall, dark stranger because an eight-year-old could read that and be like, I don't want that! Why would we?
堆满了箱子。里面塞满了细小的幸运纸条。每个箱子包含30,000张纸条。史蒂芬只和另外五名员工一起印刷了所有这些箱子。史蒂芬的女儿莉萨负责写所有的签语。我去拜访时，她正在休产假，但公司5000种独特的签语大多出自她之手。我去拜访时，她正在休产假，但公司5000种独特的签语大多出自她之手。这太神奇了，因为仔细想想，写签语其实极其困难。这些信息必须非常非常笼统，因为它们适用于任何人。你不能写诸如“你会遇到一个高大、黑发的陌生人”之类的话，因为一个八岁的孩子读到可能会想：“我才不要这个！为什么我们要？”
Infortunes also have to be careful not to offend. Famously, there was once a fortune that said, lighten up, and a lot of customers were like, is this cookie calling me fat? And of course, no bad predictions. Americans like their fortunes sunny. So fortunes tend to be vague, or just generally uplifting, like tomorrow will be better. Or the fortunes are nabbed from quotation books, just whatever Lisa can find. Steven doesn't really care, he doesn't read them. I don't know why, I make people they like it.
而且写签语还必须小心不要冒犯他人。最著名的是，曾经有一张签语写着“看开点”（lighten up），许多顾客就觉得：“这是在说我很胖吗？”当然，也不能有不好的预测。美国人喜欢积极向上的签语。因此，签语往往含糊不清，或者只是普遍令人振奋，比如明天会更好。或者这些签语是从名言警句集里摘抄的，只要莉萨能找到什么就行。史蒂芬其实并不在乎，他也不读这些。我不知道为什么，我让人们觉得他们喜欢它。
They say when they got a fortune, after eating dinner they were keeping the words, the keeper. Yeah, it's true. Some people do keep the fortunes in their wallets. When I asked around, it turns out a few of my friends do this or can recite their favorite fortunes from memory. And it's crazy because a lot of these fortunes are Stevens, written by his daughter, Lisa. But there are a few ways to tell where your fortunes come from. If you get one with blue corners on it,
他们说当他们得到一张签语时，吃完晚饭后他们会把这些字留着，作为珍藏。是的，这是真的。有些人确实把签语放在钱包里。当我四处打听时，发现我的几个朋友也这样做，或者能凭记忆背出他们最喜欢的签语。这很疯狂，因为其中许多签语都是史蒂芬的女儿莉萨写的。但有几种方法可以辨别你的签语来自哪里。如果你拿到的签语带有蓝色边缘，
that was printed by a giant company in New York called Wonton Food. They make over 4 million cookies a day and were responsible for the cookie that made all those powerball winners in 2005. If your fortune has smiley faces on it, it was probably printed by a Chinese company for the American market, of course. And if the fortune doesn't have blue corners or smiley faces, chances are it was one of the many thousands that Stephen Prince in all different colors and fonts and sends to factories all over the country, including the Golden Gate Fortune Cookie Company in a tiny alleyway in San Francisco's Chinatown. The Golden Gate Fortune Cookie Company is pretty touristy.
那是纽约一家名为“幸运面食”（Wonton Food）的大公司印刷的。他们每天生产超过400万个饼干，并且就是2005年创造了所有那些强力球中奖者的饼干的幕后推手。如果你的签语上有笑脸，那它很可能是由一家中国公司为美国市场印制的，当然。如果签语没有蓝色边缘或笑脸，那它很可能是史蒂芬用各种不同的颜色和字体印刷并发送到全国各地工厂的数千张签语之一，其中包括位于旧金山唐人街一条小巷里的金门幸运饼干公司。金门幸运饼干公司非常具有旅游色彩。
It charges visitors 50 cents a photo and doesn't actually have a very big cookie output. Actually calling this place a factory is kind of an overstatement. It's just one narrow room with most of the space taken up by three hulking fortune cookie machines. Versions of machines that were invented by Edward Lui. My father used to call his machine like his fourth child. He had three sons and then the fourth was his baby. Ming Louis, one of Edward's three sons,
它向游客收取50美分一张照片的费用，实际上饼干产量并不是很高。事实上，把这个地方称为工厂有点夸张。它只是一个狭窄的房间，大部分空间都被三台巨大的幸运饼干机器占据了。这些机器是爱德华·刘（Edward Lui）发明的机器的衍生版本。我父亲过去常常把他的机器称为他的第四个孩子。他有三个儿子，然后第四个是他的宝贝。明·刘（Ming Louis），爱德华的三个儿子之一，
met me at the Golden Gate Fortune Cookie Company. These fortune cookie machines are pretty simple. They flatten round dabs of batter onto a conveyor belt and a worker sits next to this belt and folds the hot cookies around the paper fortunes. One by one, by hand. and a worker sits next to this belt and folds the hot cookies around the paper fortunes. One by one, my hand. And we picked them off as you see them doing here,
在金门幸运饼干公司接待了我。这些幸运饼干机器非常简单。它们把一团圆形的面糊压扁在传送带上，一个工人坐在传送带旁边，把热饼干围绕着纸条折叠起来。一个接一个，手工完成。一个工人坐在传送带旁边，把热饼干围绕着纸条折叠起来。一个接一个，靠我的手。正如你在这里看到的，我们把它们拿下来，
fold it and put them on a conveyor. Ming learned how to fold the cookies when he was around eight years old. The Louis family used to have a fortune cookie company of their own, and it was their whole life. Even during dinner, we took shifts. Somebody eats, the other one works. That's how we did it, you know. We used to call ourselves the prisoners, and that was a famous thing. Help, I'm a prisoner in this Fortune Cookie Factory, you know? Ming's father later developed the next generation of Fortune Cookie machines,
折叠好然后放到传送带上。明大约八岁时就学会了如何折叠饼干。刘氏家族曾经拥有自己的幸运饼干公司，这就是他们的全部生活。甚至在晚饭时，我们也轮流值班。一个人吃饭，另一个人工作。我们就是这样做的，你知道的。我们过去常自称是囚犯，那是个很有名的梗。救命啊，我是这个幸运饼干工厂里的囚犯，你知道吗？明的父亲后来开发了下一代幸运饼干机器，
a fully automated version, which also folds the cookie. And because of this technology, fortune cookies are widely available and cheap enough that restaurants can give them out for free. No one in the Louis family really questioned where the cookies originated, but it was a mystery that other people tried to solve. People like Sally Osochi.
一个完全自动化的版本，它也可以折叠饼干。由于这项技术，幸运饼干变得随处可见，而且便宜到餐馆可以免费赠送。刘氏家族没有人真正质疑过饼干的起源，但这却是其他人试图解开的谜团。像萨莉·奥索奇（Sally Osochi）这样的人。
She knew they were not invented in China. What do you mean the Chinese fortune cookie? It's Japanese. Sally Osaka is California born and raised, but her parents came from Japan in the early 1900s. When I was a child, the fortunes used to be in Japanese rather than the Chinese character. And the cookies weren't something you'd get
她知道这些不是在中国发明的。什么叫中国幸运饼干？它是日本的。萨莉·大阪在加利福尼亚出生并长大，但她的父母在20世纪初从日本来到这里。当我还是个孩子的时候，签语通常是用日语而不是汉字写的。而且这些饼干也不是你在
at the end of a meal at a restaurant. They'd come in a bag, and mostly I know who we got them when I was a child, was we would go see Japanese movies. So in Sally's California childhood, the cookies were a casual snack. But if you trace them all the way back to their origins in Japan, you actually find them at a shrine. In Kyoto, and if you kind of walk around there, you will be able to find these Japanese bakers, like grilling fortune cookies. Jennifer Flute, the Hushimi Inari Taisha Shrine,
餐馆饭后能吃到的东西。它们装在一个袋子里，据我所知，小时候我们得到它们的主要途径是去看日本电影。所以在萨莉在加利福尼亚的童年里，这些饼干只是一种随意的零食。但如果你一直追溯到它们在日本的起源，你会发现它们其实源于一座神社。在京都，如果你四处走走，你会发现这些日本面包师在烤制幸运饼干。詹妮弗·弗鲁特（Jennifer Flute）前往位于京都的伏见稻荷大社，
in Kyoto specifically to try them. But they're not like the fortune cookies we see in the United States, they're like bigger and rounder, and they're actually kind of of this like nutty savory flavor. So they're more cracker like, but still, they're that same iconic fortune cookie shape we all know. There's actually an old Japanese image
特意去尝尝它们。但它们和我们在美国看到的幸运饼干不一样，它们更大更圆，而且实际上有一种坚果般的咸香味。所以它们更像是饼干（cracker），但它们仍然有着我们都知道的标志性的幸运饼干形状。实际上有一张古老的日本图片，
of a baker folding these crackers, and it dates back to 1878, decades before the first reports of American fortune cookies. One of the bakers that I spoke to thought that fortune cookies they designed to look like a bell in part because their bell's all along the paths up into the shrines. But then why don't we eat it after sushi?
描绘了一个面包师在折叠这些饼干，其历史可以追溯到1878年，比美国幸运饼干的首次报道早了几十年。我交谈过的一位面包师认为，幸运饼干的设计看起来像一个铃铛，部分原因是因为通往神社的小路上到处都是铃铛。但话说回来，为什么我们在吃完寿司后不吃它呢？
Because like people were not eating sushi in like 1920. When Japanese immigrants were opening businesses in the 1920s, there was no market for Japanese food. Again, like the Chinese immigrants before them, they pandered to American tastes. So a lot of the Japanese families ran a lot of Chinese restaurants. And these Japanese families ran American Chinese restaurants full of chapsuui and other faux Chinese cuisine. And these Japanese owners would throw in a fortune cookie for dessert. When Sally was a kid, fortune cookies were still made in Japanese bakeries in both
因为就像1920年代没有人吃寿司一样。当日本移民在1920年代开展业务时，日本食品并没有市场。和之前的中国移民一样，他们迎合了美国人的口味。因此，许多日本家庭经营了大量的中餐馆。这些日本家庭经营着充满了杂碎和其他仿中餐的美式中餐馆。这些日本老板会在甜点里附送一个幸运饼干。当萨莉还是个孩子的时候，洛杉矶和旧金山的日本面包店仍然在制作幸运饼干，
LA and San Francisco, and the fortunes were still in Japanese. And then something happened that completely disrupted everything about Japanese American life in this country. You know, the, I don't know if you know that the Japanese Americans, 120,000 of us, during World War II, were sent away to concentration camps. I was nine years old when we got sent to the concentration camps. Sally and her family were farmers in Fresno. They were summoned to a train station and sent off to a camp in Arizona.
而且签语仍然是日文的。然后发生了一件事，彻底打碎了这里日裔美国人生活的方方面面。你知道的，我不知道你是否知道日裔美国人，我们当中的12万人在二战期间被送往集中营。当我们被送往集中营时，我九岁。萨莉和她的家人是弗雷斯诺的农民。他们被召集到火车站，被送往亚利桑那州的一个集中营。
You had to carry whatever you were taking. That was a child. I couldn't carry that much. I carried a small suitcase. And I remember my mother took me to a store near our town to buy boots because she heard that where we were going in Arizona, there were rattlesnakes and scorpions. Were there? Oh, there were, yeah.
你必须随身携带你所带的东西。作为一个孩子，我带不了那么多。我带了一个小手提箱。我记得我母亲带我去我们镇附近的一家商店买靴子，因为她听说我们要去的亚利桑那州有响尾蛇和蝎子。真的有吗？哦，确实有，是的。
Oh, yeah. Heal of monsters and scorpions and rattlesnakes, yeah. In the camp, her parents were given jobs that earned hardly any money. Top salary was like $16 or $18 a month. For four years, from 1942 to 1946, California's Japanese and Japanese American community was marooned in the desert, out of sight, out of communication, and out of business.
哦，是的。有毒蜥蜴、蝎子和响尾蛇，是的。在集中营里，她的父母被分配了几乎赚不到钱的工作。最高薪水大概是每月16或18美元。从1942年到1946年的四年里，加利福尼亚的日本和日裔美国人社区被困在沙漠中，不为人知、与世隔绝，无法做生意。
Including a lot of Japanese bakers and Japanese restaurant owners. My recollection was that after we came out of the camps, it was the Chinese swatching cookie. The Chinese actually commercialized it and all the Chinese restaurants started to serve it. Thanks to Chinese business owners and later Edward Louis' fortune cookie machines, the Chinese American fortune cookie, as we now know it, flourished. It's nearly impossible to pin the Americanization of the cookie to one specific Japanese-American
其中包括许多日本面包师和日本餐馆老板。我的记忆是，在我们离开集中营后，就变成了中国幸运饼干。中国人实际上将其商业化了，所有的中餐馆都开始提供它。多亏了中国企业主以及后来的爱德华·刘的幸运饼干机器，我们今天所知道的美式中餐幸运饼干繁荣发展起来。几乎不可能把饼干的美国化归功于某个特定的日裔美国人
baker or Chinese-American restaurant. The transfer from Japanese cracker to American Chinese cookie was a larger phenomenon that occurred more or less across California, and then swept the rest of the United States, and then the world, except for China. They still don't eat fortune cookies. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Avery Troubleman with Katie Mingles-Sam Green Span, Kurt Colstead, and me Roman Mars. This episode was largely inspired by Jennifer A. Lee's book, The Fortune Cookie Chronicles,
面包师或美式中餐馆。从日本小饼干到美式中国饼干的转变是一个更大的现象，它或多或少发生在整个加利福尼亚州，然后席卷了美国其余地区，接着是全世界，除了中国。他们仍然不吃幸运饼干。“99%隐形”本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，合作者包括凯蒂·明格尔斯-萨姆·格林斯潘、库尔特·科尔斯特德以及我罗曼·马尔斯。这一集很大程度上受到了詹妮弗·A·李的书《幸运饼干编年史》的启发，
which goes into even more depth about the origins of American Chinese cuisine. And believe me, there are way deeper depths. It's a great read. But these days, Jennifer's got a new passion project that needs your help, designers. We have this great project with the White House and your public library, and we're inviting everyone to redesign covers for public domain books. They still need covers for titles like Peter Pan and the Secret Garden. You can learn more about it at recoveringtheclassics.com.
该书更深入地探讨了美式中餐的起源。相信我，其中还有更深的内幕。这是一本极好的书。但如今，詹妮弗有一个需要你帮助的新热情项目，设计师们。我们与白宫和你的公共图书馆有一个伟大的项目，我们邀请每个人为公共领域图书重新设计封面。他们仍然需要像《彼得·潘》和《秘密花园》这样书名的封面。你可以在 recoveringtheclassics.com 了解更多信息。
Special thanks to John Schmidt and Mithsuko Craype. Lullatone provided all the lovely music for the show this week, and if you're interested in learning more about America's Japanese concentration camps, Sally Osaki highly recommends the book Infamy by Richard Reeves. 99% of visible is a project of 91.7KA on W. San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California, right next to Oakland's Chinatown and if you're ever in Oakland's Chinatown, you gotta go to Angel Feet on 9th, get your feet rubbed, it'll make your life better. It's an unpaid endorsement for getting your feet rubbed.
特别感谢约翰·施密特和三津子·克雷普（Mitsuko Craype）。拉拉托恩（Lullatone）为本周的节目提供了所有美妙的音乐，如果你有兴趣了解更多关于美国日本集中营的信息，萨莉·奥索奇强烈推荐理查德·里夫斯（Richard Reeves）的书《耻辱》（Infamy）。“99%隐形”是加利福尼亚州旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的一家建筑与室内设计公司 Arxine 的办公室里，紧邻奥克兰唐人街，如果你去过奥克兰唐人街，你一定要去9街的“天使之足”（Angel Feet）按摩脚，这会让你的生活更美好。这是一个关于按摩脚的免费推荐。
You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify, but you can listen to every single episode of Nine Names and a Visible, and see pictures at nni-ni-pi.org. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目。我们在 Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram 和 Spotify 上都有账号，但你可以在 nni-ni-pi.org 上收听《九名与隐形》（Nine Names and a Visible）的每一集并查看图片。（背景音乐播放）当前剧集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。